yes i am
good morning everybody um
uh first time we've met is division two
i think in uh
other than i think the last time we met
on zoom
um
which was probably
close to a year ago so
it's nice to see everyone this morning
and um
i do know that representative turcotte
is um
flying someplace today i don't know if
he's over the
atlantic ocean or if he's still in
greece or if he's someplace else but uh
but that's okay um
i will also tell you that mr pitkin
is in florida
on business
which of course
when he called me yesterday and told me
that i said well
we'll be facing uh below zero tonight
and
maybe we can get up to uh
20 today so um
anyhow that's uh that's what's going on
um
and sarah welcome um why don't you just
come on up we're not
um i know that uh
you have never
been with division two before
and so we uh we certainly welcome you
and um
i will say that
we're very friendly
okay and
and
99 of the time we get along
and i think
that that's
that's one of the the fun things about
being on division two
so um i will tell you that uh
you know the speaker asked me if i
wanted to give up
my responsibility on division two and i
said no i have too much fun there so
and besides mickey would be lonely
if uh if i wasn't annoying him every day
so
okay
um the first thing we're going to um
look at
and the reason sarah's here is uh
hb 300
and
i believe you've seen the amendment
right
i have okay i also have an uh and some
additional information based on the
comments of the group last session yeah
could you move the mic a little
okay there you go how's that is that
better that's much better thank you
great so thank you so much for having me
here again we really appreciate the
discussion at the last work session all
of these questions bring up great
discussion back at our office how we can
better serve the citizens of the state
des wholeheartedly agrees with the
comments that i was hearing from this
group during the last work session that
econ's situation is difficult and unique
and warrants flexibility beyond what
we've been finding in the rules and in
the statutes
and for that reason we've been working
with econ for a number of months to
find a way to achieve that flexibility
that's needed
it's important that des stay within its
authority
as we do this and it's important that
whatever agreement we come to is
documented in writing and signed off on
by both econ and des so in the future
there is no confusion about what the
agreement was
and based on our discussions with the
department of justice the vehicle that's
available to us to come to that written
agreement in an organized way is an
administrative order by consent
when i was here last time i wasn't sure
how much i could talk about about that
because we're in negotiations right now
on that but in speaking with doj they
told me it's fine to talk about it here
within certain limits because the
administrative order by consent has been
discussed also at a public meeting of
econ
so
based on the advice from doj i can't
share the details of the negotiations or
the details of what that agreement will
have in it
but i'm very glad to let the committee
know that we're working with econ
on an agreement with the goal of
providing econ with flexibility and
reliefs in the short term
in order to
assure compliance in the future and to
be sure that the landfill doesn't become
a financial burden on the citizens of
the state of new hampshire
in order to move forward with those
negotiations that began in august we
needed the updated post-closure cost
estimate from econ and we received that
just after the last work session
our engineers are currently talking with
econs engineers they had a discussion
yesterday afternoon
along the lines of us trying to gain an
understanding of where some of the
numbers in the estimate come from
and we were on course to come to an
agreement with econ
and i'm happy to answer any of your
questions about that and any other
questions that you may have
sorry please
go ahead
plug me am i i am um so does that mean
we don't need this bill
and we can go forward we can itl this
bill
uh well we think that we can come to
uh the very needed flexible agreement um
that econ needs that will suit both the
state's needs and econs it just
if i may go ahead please um
i would always prefer not to put into
legislation something related to one
specific event
so it seems that this bill is
unnecessary if in fact you have employed
measures within your agency
within the guidelines that allow for
this
madam speaker i mean
[Laughter]
oh no thank you i don't i don't want
that promotion i appreciate it um
question for you does that seem logical
uh yes thank you
yes please kate
thank you madam chair
just
to be
broad about this i'm not casting
aspersions on anything but i just feel
the need to you know put this out there
i appreciate that you can't share a lot
of the details
actually i don't understand why you
can't share a lot of details but that's
fine i trust that you do
apropos
what representative
heath was saying and what we have to do
here
i have to ask what level of trust do we
have that you will come to an agreement
you're talking about you're in the
process of doing this
what assurance is that's a good word
here
do we have that you will reach this
without having to go through a
legislative process and again i don't
mean any disrespect but i just need to
ask the question about how
can you assure us that this will be done
sure
well it's something that we are actively
working on
um
as i think was pointed out in
in the last work session
and as econ has pointed out many times
one
option that that econ has has explained
that they have is to dissolve and to no
longer provide the support for this
landfill
that is not something that anyone wants
to see happen it's not something we want
to see happen at des
because of the financial liability that
that would bring on to the state
um
recognizing that in order to come to
agreement both both sides have to agree
in the end
i think that we're on track to do that
we have the details of the agreement to
work out
regarding why i can't talk about the
details of the negotiations it's
technically enforcement negotiations
with the attorneys on both sides
involved so those discussions are
confidential
i wish i could share
[Music]
so i hope that that answers your
question
when it's done will we get an update of
what that agreement looks like or is
that confidential too
the agreement when it is in place
i'm not aware that it would be
confidential that wouldn't be normal i
suppose econ could ask for that but
i'm
i can't think of why they would so it
would be available
are there are there any other questions
yeah
oh thank you chair thank you for taking
my question
now you said that the state would be
responsible wouldn't the responsibility
let's say econ goes out of business
would
the
liability go back to the 27
municipalities that have
you know that put that waste there
i mean you know i know there's an
agreement between econ but
you know it seems so the state shouldn't
be i mean it's it's it's going to be
it's going to be a fight but right
um
yeah we would need for our attorneys to
look at that there is this agreement
between those communities and econ that
was put in place when econ became um the
owner of the landfill
um
and
it could take a long time to work that
out
in the interim there would still need to
be
care taken of the landfill
and
when no one else is stepping up
when there is environmental risk
presented
leachate that needs to be disposed of
that sort of thing
then
if no one else is doing it then the
state would have a responsibility
okay
um
i guess that
my thought process is at this point
that if you follow through
on this
um
then there's no need for this bill is
that
is that how people
feel
okay okay
um
our
exact session is on the 8th
and so
we will need
[Music]
something by the eighth
and um
because if
you know if
if we don't
know all you have to tell us is there's
an agreement
you don't have to go into details
you just have to say we've made the
agreement right i mean
is that agreeable
i don't believe that we will have an
agreement in place by the eighth i
didn't i didn't say you needed to have
the agreement
in place
the two parties have to agree as to
what is going to go into the agreement
that's all i'm asking
given the availability of the parties
involved including our attorney i'm not
sure whether that would be possible
because today's the first that's one
week from today right
right
um
because there are a number of people who
are are out on vacation because it's
school vacation week right now tell them
to come back
we can find them
you know could i just ask i mean one of
the things um
arguably what and i don't i mean i don't
know what how everyone else feels but
arguably
it might be satisfactory if
i would think that the problem would be
you know at the worst case scenario
somehow you don't arrive at an agreement
and i guess the
um if we if we had if we took a vote
today let's say to to
to uh
render this building in expedient to
legislate
um
and
then you didn't come to an agreement
obviously that could i mean that could
be a problem uh and so i guess what i'm
what i'm wondering is
is the
because because then we couldn't do
anything until the next legislative
session and so i guess the the only
question would be let's assume you
didn't come to an agreement what's the
likelihood that the state would and then
institute some enforcement action
you know within the next year
i'm not really
able to speak on behalf of the
commissioner about how likely he is to
institute enforcement um but
our efforts have really been focused on
negotiating a settlement that
serves both parties needs
okay thank you
yes so
yes go ahead sorry madam chair thank you
um
madam speaker i like i do like that
thing
um
would it be possible just to interim
study this and then that would give us
the tools with which to work if we need
to
i mean i would prefer just to be done
with this if possible
and not have to entertain it again um
but
in light of the uncertainty
maybe we just need to hold on to it a
little bit longer
because we can always act on it at any
point right
out of interim study
i don't
let me ask janet
okay
i mean i'd like to be done with it thank
you for so would i
i might be able to help on this as far
as the date so the last day to report
house bills is march 24th
yes so i think if you did an interim
study
you'd still be subject to that i don't
think you could take it out of interim
study after your report deadline of
house bills
okay so i could skip the 10th deadline
yeah if you didn't if you say say we
took this off of exec session for the
eighth i think we've got until um
and i guess this could be a question
the the tenth deadline was bill's um not
in a second committee i'm not sure if
that applies to this bill because he's
not subject to a second committee but
the last day to report all house bills
is the 24th of march
so i don't know if this bill will be
subject to that deadline
okay deadlines
what is the deadline for this bill
this is the
i don't think an interim study would
help in that deadline
if yeah if if you reported it you
wouldn't be able to
change that or pass that bill this
session
excuse me i should probably talk so
everybody can hear
what
what's going on is
des and the parties are pretty close to
an agreement
okay
but they don't think that
they will have the head nods
prior to the eighth
okay so the result is
that
we we were thinking about itlling it if
they could get back to us by the eighth
which they don't think they can do
and so we wanted some sort of
way
that we could
kill it
after the
tenth or the 8th
yeah
once once we get them to
you know that both parties agree to this
yeah so
okay
can i ask a question or two questions
sure what's the second committee and the
second question is if we pass this with
the amendment you know sometimes we'll
pass something
you know just in just in case um and the
agreement goes through can we when it
goes to the full house ask the house to
itl it because it's already been
considered we can do that and what one
what's the second committee is it going
to and no it's not going to assume so
it's not a second committee but the
deadline's still the 10th right
that's for all bills
that are in our possession
that are not second committee bills
thank you
yes ma'am chair because we do not intend
to give them 500 000
absolutely so that's our job
so maybe
with that consideration we know we're
not going to give them money
um and we're not a policy committee
so maybe it's just a matter of saying no
in this case
we are
because
because it affects the money
okay
i mean
can i make one other suggestion i don't
know whether this oh sure that makes
sense or not but what
could we i i did not want this dilemma
this morning
could could we
adopt your proposed amendment
recommend that as ought to pass
and then if they do come to an agreement
ask on the floor that it be tabled or
itl or ito what is it one of them we'd
like to yell it right i'm not i'm not a
big favor of tabling by the way in case
anybody wanted to know
so
the 10th
that would
that would probably let's say we're
meeting the
we're meeting the 10th
and then the following week
i don't know if we're meeting both
wednesday and thursday
there's you know
that depends on
what we have so
how about another week
to get back to us
it's possible
where i understand we are is we have had
a discussion between engineers
um
talked about get them providing some
additional information
and so um
the timeline for for when that
information would be provided is a
little bit out of our hands
so um
so it's possible but i can't commit to
two weeks for sure
one more question man of chance listen
lots of questions no problem tom did you
want i'm sorry
i it's not it sounds as though um they
need some incentive to to
get this
get this agreement
under in in in our time frame
um
so can't we just say well you know
if if if it's not prepared by next week
we're going to itl this bill or we're
going to
adopt this amendment or whatever
representative heath
mike in in at our last meeting um we
said we wanted to go back and look at
the rules
and i think um we saw that
representative mari did do that
and we identified the fact that those
rules
were put in place
after the newport agreement had been
established
therefore
we shouldn't be even doing this dance
this should be
something that i believe why do they
need to be held to that and they have
funding
to keep the landfill
what what they don't have is 500 000
yeah what they don't have is the 500
000. but they can't be held to that
level of funding i thought
at this point they can because right
because that was
des interpretation
of of what they needed
even after they had a signed agreement
with all the towns
agreeing to the closure
and the guidelines thereof
everybody signed off on it
and the des signed off on it and then
another set of rules were
established afterwards that all of a
sudden became applicable to that
situation
that's how i understand it
that that's why
you know
how about we do this
okay
i like the idea
of
adopting the amendment
and
if they're able to get back to us prior
to
whatever day it's coming up in the
calendar on the floor on the floor
they let us know
what if they've come to an agreement
and then
we will recommend itel
on the floor
can i ask a question just following up
on that because we have the session on
the 10th
proposed sessions on the 16th the 17th
and the
31st
do you have discretion about when you
can ask the speaker to put something on
the calendar
i can try because that gives them maybe
a little bit more time and you know our
goal is to itl it
and once we have confidence in the
agreement then we can have that get on
the calendar fry tail so if we can push
that if it's possible to push that back
it gives them a little more both of them
a little more breathing space
and i would like to hear that icon as
econ is happy
yeah i make one more comment and this
this is really
this this is
and i apologize for this i mean i think
this i i think on the merits i really
like this amendment i think it you know
it makes
my only concern is i thought about this
just a little bit further which kind of
goes against what i said earlier is this
if we
the parties are now in the process of
negotiating with each other presumably
each side has their you know what they
like you know
as i understand this amendment if we
adopt this amendment
we are essentially i think saying that
exactly what you said which may be you
know my inclination is you're absolutely
right we are essential we would
essentially be saying that our position
at least on this committee is that all
econ has to do is kind of comply with
what it originally agreed to
if we pass this
that could affect the negotiations
because econ may say why you know why
should i why should i agree to anything
else i've got the legislature on record
saying
and and so that's my only concern we we
are
by taking that action we may be
influencing their negotiation okay
then how about this
i like uh
the idea of interim study
that allows
the negotiations to go on
um
we've denied the
500 000
and um
i guess we'll see what happens
but i you know i do think that uh
des and econ are
in
good negotiations and are
working diligently to solve the problem
within the
confines of the dollars that are
available
i would make that motion madam speak
chair okay i don't know why i wanted to
call you the speaker today
only because i'm speaking it's just
wishful thinking i don't know
motion's in place
okay
anything else
other than mickey thank you for putting
this amendment together i know it's not
the first one that we have ignored
so
thank you
all right um
are you when you're ready you can call
the role
so this is on uh hp 1300
fn it's on the motion for uh
interim study uh representative feature
uh yes
representative votes yes uh
representative
absent uh representative
yes
representative
yeah yes umber yes
okay
and
representative lin did indicate that he
would write up the blurb
is there anyone else that wants to fight
him for that
[Laughter]
okay
seeing none sarah thank you and um
please let us
as soon as possible
as to
what's
absolutely
how about if i plan a time right now for
an update regardless of what the status
is
what time period would be would be good
for division two
i could send you an email with the
update so it would be yeah that that
would be just as soon as you can okay
okay will do
thank you very much for having me oh my
pleasure it's our pleasure to
visit with the folks from des
thank you
okay
um we have one other bill
to get rid of today
much easier
uh this is hb 1054 which was um
requiring an audit of the state police
and the
sponsor
basically said please itl
so
could i have a motion
second thank you thank you any just any
discussion on this
okay seeing none
right uh the clerk motion to itl
um
uh representative petrie yes
uh representative lynn votes yes uh
representative bucco yes representative
heath
representative murray
and representative umber yes vote is six
to zero i'm sure
okay now
is there anyone here that wants to fight
representative mooney for writing this
[Music]
um blur
okay she said she would i said okay
that's one less we have to uh we have to
worry about okay
so um
we'll
take care of that
on uh on the eight
um let's see
i did uh i did want to let you know that
um
i don't have the calendar in my head
uh 10th 11th
must be the 14th
um
i'm going to schedule
uh three bills
that morning at 10 o'clock
and then on tuesday
three bills
on tuesday it's the education bills
and on
monday
it's the um
safety and
pfcs or whatever they're called
is this full finance or
both these days or div too
yeah i'm sorry so that's monday the 14th
and then the 15th also at 10 right
yeah we don't have to have uh public
hearings
because they've already had public
unless there's something that uh
you know
i feel there needs to be a public
hearing
i don't have them
yeah let me go get the bill numbers
sure
very valuable lady in there okay
uh
1462.
this is uh for monday this is for monday
and 1547
and then for tuesday
tuesday 16
and 1661.
okay the other thing i want to say
is that on the 8th at 1 o'clock
we're going to have a hearing on a
non-germane amendment
to
and i think mickey you sent that out to
everybody right
uh it will be sent out i think janet's
officially going to schedule it today
and then it's going to be uh in the
account the next calendar it'll be
mailed out okay and just just so you
know it's um
we had a discussion with d.o.e
and there is a
a way is that the right term
a way
to
have uh
the department of department of
agriculture
agree that we can use
medicaid data
for free and reduced lunch
okay
so
that's the non-germane amendment
and um
you know we i hope that uh
the bill that it's attached to is the um
establishment of a position in doe
to monitor the efas so
i felt that that was something that
we could all support
and
that's why i
chose this particular bill to put it on
but
i'm really really excited that uh
doe has been able to uh to do that and
basically
they asked us if we would put
legislation that they had to do it
so
okay i'm i'm easy yes
thank you thank you madam chair this is
something that i know when i was at the
department
we always lost so many children who we
knew were eligible for these dollars but
because for whatever reason the parents
didn't get the paperwork or they didn't
feel comfortable doing the paperwork
this will make a difference for for
food insecurity um to help so many
children so thank you very much i think
it'll make a big difference based on the
numbers that the deal we give us
yeah and i you know um
there will still have to be the forms
filled out
for those children whose
income
you know falls into that but they do
have health insurance so
those those forms would still come in
but this is to me
i think uh
just a just a wonderful thing to occur
and of course it's going to
perhaps
have some
financial impact in the future but
until we until we know what we know
i'm not gonna worry about that
okay
um
i'm sorry it's only half an hour that i
brought you in here
for for such a short thing but
we will um
we will press on
and
i am
i really think that d.o.e got the
message
that
we were not
happy
and so
they
decided that
they could do something different
can i ask one more question when we were
talking about the data there was one
other thing that we had
talked about was the um going back and
looking at information over time
and it appears that they said that they
didn't have the authority to do some of
that
um did we did we provide them with that
because it seemed like when i was at the
department we used to look at
longitudinal data
but now
when we hit we're having our free
reduced lunch conversation
it seemed that they
said that they
weren't able to do that
i think it was a problem they don't have
the data
i don't think it's that they can't do it
but because they didn't have the
information
without 4c they should have the data
with with with their data system they
should have longitudinal data but not on
free and reduced lunch
i don't you know they have what they
have in the infam
all right i i think that i think that
with um
moving towards getting the information
from uh
medicaid that it will allow them to do a
lot more
because right now as you know everything
is by student number
and there's no
cross-reference on that so
okay
um
is there anything i'm forgetting i just
want i had these senate bills right
what all the numbers that you read no
their house bills their second committee
house bills okay thank you
we haven't gotten any senate bills
okay
thank you
yet
see what happens
but um
i will
i will still ask the speaker
if uh or paul
if we can schedule 1300 for the 31st
and that will
hopefully give us
leverage
that's the right term
yeah
okay thank you very much by the way if
um
if anyone is interested in um
listening to um
what's going on with the ydc bill
uh there's going to be another work
session on that at two o'clock today
and if anyone is interested in
dental benefits
that's at one o'clock right
yeah
so you know um
we'll
i think i think on both of those which
are in division three there's
work that still needs to be done but
i will i will say this
um about
1677.
there have been so many changes from the
uh initial bill
that
it's almost like
that bill doesn't exist anymore
it's been
how many times have we rewritten that
three two
three
yeah yeah so
anyhow
it's um i and i think it's overall a
much better bill
than what we started with and uh
so we'll see where that one goes but we
will be executing it on the 8th
oh the economic briefing yes
yeah
yeah i have three meetings at that time
on friday so um
i'm not exactly sure
what
yeah but yes the economic briefing will
be streamed
is it nine
i thought it was ten
well i guess i'll go to one of my other
meetings
no
um
oh the other thing is um
janet had gone out and asked if anybody
was interested in
sitting with ways and means on the
marijuana bill
and um
the only person that came back was
robert de bears
and said that yes he would like to
and keith irf told me
that
he would do it
okay
um i don't think he was real excited but
no one else has
no one else has volunteered so
i will put the two of them on that
on that committee
because there's
there's some things
especially the 24 million dollars they
want
okay otherwise listen i'm sorry that uh
especially tom that had to drive two
hours this morning to uh to get down
here but uh i appreciate it and
we'll see you soon
now